si vous l'évaluez avec les x-men ou
que vous arrivez avec quoi faites-vous mon travail, c'est
vous qui avez dit que j'étais prêt et
je suis franchement en désaccord avec vous mais ici
nous essayons de surmonter nos différences
comme le dit Beyonce s'il vous plaît arrêtez de
tricher  sur moi hé c'est le cinquième
incident cet enfant doit être la glacière
pas ici
Russell appartient à nos soins pas en
prison je vous assure que nous avons tout
sous contrôle
ne pas obtenir une véritable ambiance sous contrôle
ici Marty c'est Glenn n'est-ce pas Daniel
Je vais poser les questions, laissez-moi parler
au gamin que vous restez ici avec vos étranges
lèvres sexuelles secrètes, vous êtes adorable, je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai emballé les points creux,
venez-vous de dire des points creux, ouais,
j'aurais probablement dû apporter un SuperSoaker.
Oh les
cuisses de Justin Bieber ah c'est le Bieber qu'il
t'a appelé Justin Bieber
attends ok ne faisons pas tout ce
qui est ok parlons juste bien alors
c'est Russell droit tirez le premier poing de feu
ooh c'est un super nom où est-ce qu'il
brûle juste le poing  ou
tout le chemin jusqu'au coude définitivement jusqu'au coude viens
tranquillement ou il y aura des problèmes tu as
volé ça au robot Robocop reste juste
debout tu m'embarrasse regarde le feu
qui fera je n'ai jamais vu réussir
avant
le guavian  copie ou excitation cachée
et Oh aïoli au poivre voir si je suis sur
c'est livret de vente un nez
servir un tofu
ocotillo cognition ou sangganim était une
puce minuscule un principe pas d'égalité
pour des corps bien humains